we're glad to welcome back tekken 7 it's
definitely on the cal crumb pro tour
again this year and we're happy to
welcome back Street Fighter 5 arcade
edition blaze BlueCross tag battle - Evo
2019 Super Smash Brothers ultimate - Evo
2019 Dragon Ball fighters back at evoke
2019 Soul Calibur 6 Mortal Kombat 11
Samurai Shodown it's time for them to
make their game a main title at evo 2019
so for the first time ever we're proud
to announce that under night in birth
executable latest or as the cool kids
say unist is a title for their that what
that said that's a goodbye forever ended
why don't you defend us
contrary to popular belief melee is not
dead
[Music]
being an Evo is the most important thing
for a fighting game at least from the
outside looking in and for most
franchises a newer flashier sequel would
almost always take the old ones place at
Evo but not for smash 18 years after its
launch melee is still considered by his
fans to be the perfect smash game
there's never gonna be another mailing
we're just gonna play melee forever I
have no problem playing melee forever I
don't get why everybody wants a new
melee we don't need a new mailing what's
wrong with we don't want a new mailing
we have mailing if mailing could survive
the disaster that was brawl three
Hardware generations and a developer
that's been stifling its competitive
scene since day one it can survive not
being an Evo makes the comeback he beats
all four dogs in the way
but I have to say it's out of winners
regardless of who wins that was a
beautiful display on high level super
smash brothers melee congratulations to
TSM weapon for taking first bliss but
that's not to say that it'll continue
being the biggest game in competitive
smash to really understand melee you
have to know where it came from the
smash community took a 2001 party game
and turned it into one of the most
technical and complicated fighting games
of all time attack players are on their
feet again oh my god the crowd going by
left side wow did not know where that
was going
their efforts were recognized by Evo in
2007 but the game was quickly replaced
the next year by Super Smash Brothers
Brawl a game designed to sterilize
mailers all to sophisticated game lines
everything that made melee great the
combo system with hit stop the various
movement options
it had all been lost in translation Evo
rain brawl with items on and random
stages an affront to the melee community
and by 2009 there were no smash games at
Eva so when Evo announced in 2013 that
they'd be welcoming an additional game
to the lineup through a charity drive
the mailee community left at the
opportunity and we have to barely you
know get snipers and get every single
person we knew to donate any one of the
can waste 94,000 damn dollars it's
ridiculous Oh barely million illusion
oh nice down a to save himself just for
in that one situation it is up smash and
wattles
is gonna go down 3-1 main go
come all the way back from losers
bracket put there by wobbles on the back
of mangos historical loser's bracket run
Malee's platinum age began at the time I
think that was everything for the smash
community because for the longest time
smash was kind of that sleeper underdog
competitive game where people knew that
it had an eSports scene knew that it had
a competitive community but for the most
part flew very much so under the radar
and this was you know this is like a
return to glory almost for the
competitive side of the community melee
saw five more Evo's each as glorious and
anticipated as the last
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
Mele steadily solidified itself as one
of Evo's largest and most entertaining
tournaments and it was a symbiotic
relationship every year Meili is a
largest tournament was an Evo both in
terms of entrance and a viewership our
first big year back was 2013 yes we
really appreciate all of the viewership
all of the new fans 2016 biggest
tournament ever we hope to continue that
trend year after year yes Meili has
returned to Evo led to an increase in
the game's popularity and to Evo's you
know one of the things that I did love
about Evo was that I mean about melee
was that it kind of showed that you know
games can survive bit by being you know
despite being you know cold unquote
melee was kind of the one that bucked
that trend right it actually showed that
you know older games could survive and
could still thrive and then in December
2018 smash ultimate
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the game was heralded as a sincere
effort from Nintendo to bring together
smashes to competitive communities
[Music]
is your champion of the Super Smash
potentional 2018 and it was a huge
success from what I've seen and I've
talked to some smash people here and
there and asking them so you know how is
ultimate you know with the community
right now and they've all told me that
the the smash community is fully
embracing the game they love the game
and you know they it doesn't seem to be
any like crazy problems of like really
terrible balance it feels like to me
that ultimate is is being really
successful so far it's at Smash foreign
and brawl specifically you know there
was a lot of excitement around the game
but it didn't really click with melee
players whereas this game it seems like
a lot more melee players who are
interested in it
that's what's been huge for Spanish
ultimate just the fact that melee
players are willing to give it a chance
but then evil announce that there would
only be one smash game in the tournament
in 2019 ultimate so for the first time
ever we're proud to announce that under
night in berth executable latest or as
the cool kids say unist
is a title for evo 2019 needles to say
this didn't go over very well with the
melee community the world don't see it I
mean mainly had a great time to you
don't even [ __ ] talk to us don't even
talk to us every alternate player should
boycott Eva and just not go
like guilty
Evos 2019 lineup features a few titles
that raised some eyebrows Soulcalibur 6
is the first SC game at Evo in years and
Mortal Kombat 11 hasn't even come out
yet but the two titles that earned the
most ire from melee fans were
up-and-coming anime fighter under Knight
and birth and the also unreleased
samurai shodown ii 7 it would have been
ok Live Arcade Edition caliber 6 they
replaces on that 11 with [ __ ] night
in birth 9 games
Samurai Shodown some of my league's
biggest names accused of developers and
publishers of buying these games into
IVA now now as I said that in my my
personal guess is that other games pay
their way in and obviously Nintendo
didn't pay for melee to be in so we kind
of got like scooped out others have
claimed that this simply isn't true I
don't think it's a thing I really don't
think it's a thing and you know I'm
pretty sure that the decision process is
not mired in this kind of like hey you
know spots up for auction kind of thing
I'm pretty sure that's not how it works
I look III know that the evil yeah I
know the guys running right and you know
for years they have been saying that
nobody can buy their spot into evil
whatever the case may be it's clear that
some members of the melee community feel
like their game deserves to be at Evo
and that other games don't like imagine
if smash con have like 1500 or 2000
entrants for mailing like when Evo have
some games does not get 1500 entrants
and this same AoE getting 1500 smash
Kong then they might wonder they might
think was this really the right choice
and I can tell them it was not but you
know everyone needs to learn their
lesson others felt as if the time had
finally come for me to step aside yeah I
think that's really coming from a place
of privilege if I'm being honest I don't
think any title it should be a given
at an event like Evo you know it's it's
a it's a privilege to be part of the
events lineup I think you know it's it's
kind of like you know being that old man
and and passing the torch on to the to
the to the young kids you know
everything it's like it's like we've had
our moment in the Sun now you you may
shine now you know because like I said I
don't think Mele is gonna have any
problems without being at Evo you know I
think it's really cool to try you know
to give a lot of these other games that
Eva was shot so one reason for this
which is far from trivial is the
outdated hardware required to run melee
tournaments I don't know man if I had to
guess I'd say the [ __ ] CRT is a fun
being real I don't I don't blame anyone
for hating those those things if you're
ever walking or driving down the street
and you see a CRT on the curb the first
thing you think is oh maybe a melee
flavor because I mean honestly CRTs are
literally disappearing right I mean like
there's only so many of them there and
in the United States I feel like you
know 70% of all CRTs are probably open
the other reason is ultimate a game that
sold 5 million copies in its first week
alone Evo expects it to be the biggest
game at the tournament and it's the
closest thing the smash community has
ever seen to a worthy successor to melee
and whether they like it or not
the future of smash but at this point
with ultimate and ultimate is being such
a like I feel like an overall success
and from what I've heard a lot of the
smash community is just like really
loving that the way this game is playing
right now you know I feel what it kind
of is a little bit the right time to
move on a little bit and I'm guessing
that's probably kind of where Evo is
coming from as well melee is not dead
but that doesn't mean it hasn't started
to decline well I mean if if you look at
a lot of majors I would say that the
attendance is definitely getting lower
across the board in a lot of regions the
the fact that players like Armada of
Retired you know peepees been out of the
game for so long
hasn't really been someone that stepped
up at least in the last you know six
months or so that's really taken off
their spots but that doesn't mean Mele
has to die it boasts one of the most
resilient communities in all of
competitive gaming if the smash
community continues to support the game
the way they always have it'll stand the
test of time as one of those immortal
effervescent games that people always
play like if I had to have a message to
melee fans I would just be like don't
let it go away like keep playing it
keeping feverish about your game and and
you know keep making sure that it has
you know the limelight where it can get
it you know and like I said I'm such a
fan of the old games I don't feel like
there's a reason to stop playing them in
the first place so you know hopefully
hopefully melee isn't going anywhere
hopefully it'll be it'll be sticking
around for quite some time
[Applause]
everyone today taupe weapon is our evil
2018 super smash brothers melee champion
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]